this was the logic of a 20 year old boy
who didn't know women at all if you like
a girl which doesn't like you back
enough the worst thing you can do is be
like oh you don't understand I'm never
leaving
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen you notice this
guy's Mazzone Pau Gasol Julian loves
music please give it up for mr. Julian
McCullough all right
so I grew up in a musical family we care
too much about music and it hurt me real
bad uh I'm actually named after Julian
Cannonball Adderley that's Miles Davis a
saxophone player which is a lot of
pressure to put on a tiny white baby but
my dad loves jazz and not even the jazz
you don't like he likes way worse chance
my dad liked avant-garde jazz which is
the kind of psyche and the drummer is
playing a different song
so I've always cared too much about
music I get to college I make the
biggest mistake you could possibly make
in college besides to go to Rutgers I
fell batshit head-over-heels crazy in
love with the most maladjusted toxic
girl I could possibly find but when
you're 20 you're like they're the
hottest so there were red flags
everywhere she walked into class four
days late that was the first time I ever
saw four days late and a half an hour
late that day she walked in head-to-toe
all black black hair covered in tattoos
sunglasses sits down in the front row
loud and pissed off like like she was
trying to sleep and we built a classroom
around her she never took her sunglasses
off the whole time at 10 a.m. so you're
either drunk or an asshole either way I
was like I'm Julian was your name and so
I asked her out and she says no the
first time I asked her out nine more
times this is when I was young I was
hungry I was persistent I'm not like
that at all anymore now I'm like a cat
on a windowsill with women you know what
I mean I'm like now they're like no and
I'm like I have the Sun so
she finally agrees to go out with me you
know what I mean and it's amazing it
works we start dating we're boyfriend
and girlfriend I can't believe it I've
never had a real girlfriend in college
yet and she's dangerous and out of my
league I'm like it's amazing the problem
is it was never even I was obsessed with
this girl and she was like kind of on
board that she had a boyfriend from
English class like that was the two
levels we were at I don't have you've
ever been in a relationship that uneven
before but if you haven't I highly
recommend it because if you're confident
it'll fix it so we're going out but I'm
miserable the whole time I'm basically
chasing my own girlfriend in this
relationship and it wasn't completely
one-sided you know we did have a song
together she didn't know that we had a
song together but I picked a song for
both of us that I would listen to alone
in the dark when she wouldn't call and
it was called lover you should have come
over by Jeff Buckley at the very intense
love song from the 90s
yeah he drowned anyway I'm laying there
in the dark one night in my room alone
listening to the song and I get an
epiphany from the lyrics about how to
handle my situation one of the lyrics is
she's a tear that hangs inside my soul
forever and I was like yup but I called
her a tear and that's when I was like oh
my god she's had a sad life you know
what I mean like her dad ran out on the
family her mom was addicted to pills for
ex-boyfriend sold all her stuff for
drugs one time when she came home
everybody that's ever said I love you -
this girl has also completely screwed
her over so she thinks because I say I
love you I'm going to screw her over I
need to prove to her that I'm never
going to leave and then she'll love me
back this was the logic of a 20 year old
boy who didn't know women at all because
if you like a girl if she doesn't like
you back enough the worst thing you
could do is be like oh you don't
understand I'm never leaving
what I should have done is been like
let's go to lunch and then just left her
in a field somewhere and if she ever
made it back to town she'd be like you
need a blowjob you're mysterious so I
didn't know that at the time you know I
was like 25 when I found that out so uh
so I get into pimping in bed and I get
out of bed that night and I'm like I
know what I'm going to do I walk a block
down to the tattoo parlor that's close
to my apartment right you don't know
what's going to happen I walk in and I
go I would like one tattoo please I
think I was like first time and I was
like you don't know my life he goes what
are we doing I go all right I'm in love
with my girlfriend she's kind of on
board we need to fix it we have a song
together that she doesn't know about
where he says she's a tear that hangs
inside my soul forever she has a
butterfly tattoo on her bicep which is
really cool I need that butterfly tattoo
on my stomach where our souls are with
tears above it
and he goes wait what do you say because
uh oh no no way dude I'm not giving you
that tattoo and I was I couldn't believe
I was like what do you to tattoo store I
give you money you give me a tattoo he
goes that's not how it works that's the
worst thing I've ever heard in my entire
life I'm never giving you that I go but
but I love her he goes how long you been
together
I go six months you go get out of my
store I'm not giving you that
tattoo I go fine I'll just go somewhere
else and get a worse one you know now he
knows I'm mature so he goes ah all right
look go home wait seven days if you come
back you still want it and you're not
drunk I'll give it to you and I was like
you're on and he was like
it's not a challenge I don't want to do
this
so I go home I wait seven days I listen
to the song over and over again I go
back in put $200 on the counter and he
gives me this so uh that was 15 years
ago
if you're wondering if tattoos are
permanent and it's somehow brighter
today than the day I got it I don't know
how that happened it's supposed to fade
right about an hour into it
he's like I'm done I looked down it was
a black outline and I must have said
gayer because it's rainbow-colored on
the inside I don't know why I thought
that would be a good idea that was 15
years ago I've been doing comedy for 13
years this is the first year I've ever
talked about this on stage that's how
long it took me to be okay with it
not because of you guys you guys are
very supportive but all my friends are
comedians you can't show this to a
comedian they won't talk about anything
else ever I don't even want to get off
stage right now and go back to the green
room
I show it to one comedian friend one
time and he goes oh why didn't you just
get two dudes buttfucking on your
stomach that would have been less gay I
said because those weren't the lyrics
you guys are awesome thank you so much
[Music]